we were lucky to grow up in an
entrepreneurial family we built our
first company when we were seven and
five ish it was the books done and
really learned from our dad just selling
right maybe hearing 10 rejections before
lunch and just picking back up and
trying to sell again and that was just a
core memory that was our lemonade stand
I think a few things can can bring you
closer to someone than creating and
building
something together it's been the Journey
of a lifetime to build something
with my sister it was very lucky
circumstance that me and itsy were at
the GSB together I think it actually got
us to truly think about what it would be
like to start something together not
only did we think of the idea for Via
but also we tested our own co-founder
you know dynamic
via is a platform that helps companies
hire internationally in a seamless and
risk-free way we help you take care of
all of the admin burdensome boring
things about hiring someone in a new
country specifically taking care of all
of their contracts local payroll
benefits and maintaining ongoing
compliance hiring internationally is
really complex and so what we're doing
is basically making it really simple our
mission at Via is enabling any company
to be a global organization the name via
is actually a bridge or a connection or
a path from one place to another which
is in a sense what we're doing
[Music]
a lot of the the why for me is also just
representing something bigger than the
company or the mission itself it's
really clear that female Founders are
underrepresented
female Tech Founders right Latina
Founders you name it instead of thinking
about kind of the challenges or thinking
like you're the one that is different I
like to think of who's coming next right
and how do I want to act for for them
part of the reason and the energy behind
what we're building is what are we
representing and what sort of example
are we putting out there for others that
might be looking for you know a role
model that is not typical and the more
you can act that way the less issues you
see with being different and the more
you see that as being an opportunity
really to have a different perspective
and to bring something new and different
to the table
[Music]
word for
the B was inspiration every single day
it was you know from
the conversation you had over coffee
before class to the guest speaker to who
you were meeting for dinner it's almost
like it gives you the confidence to be
able to start something you really can
create a bespoke and unique experience
that fits what you're looking for in
life and and in your career I'm Maite
and I'm co-founder of via I'm it's here
and I'm co-founder of yeah
foreign
[Music]